we showed you how to make pasta from
scratch now let's get a little more
specific and talk gnocchi the light and
pillowy potato dumpling of your dreams
we'll show you how to get that perfect
texture and teach you how to make two
classic sauces to pair with it a creamy
pomodoro and a rich and delicious brown
butter sage sauce this is how to make
the best homemade gnocchi
[Music]
to make the perfect gnocchi you only
need potatoes eggs flour and salt which
seems pretty simple but like most things
the devil is in the details here's what
we mean after a bit of research we found
the master ratio for the perfect serving
of gnocchi 1 4 teaspoon of salt 1 large
egg yolk 1 pound potato and 1 4 cup
double o flour the perfect serving of
gnocchi but it gets even deeper than
that first don't just grab any potato we
recommend using russet potatoes these
potatoes are high in starch which means
they'll produce a lighter and fluffier
dough and we are chasing that perfect
texture right right
pierce your potatoes with a fork so they
can release steam and then roast until
tender
ready to have your world rocked if you
want to get perfect gnocchi bake don't
boil potatoes are super absorbent and
they'll take on too much moisture during
the boiling process this means you'll
need more flour when making your dough
which will weigh your gnocchi down and
we don't want that we're looking for a
light pillowy texture and a super dry
potato gets us there always weigh your
potatoes raw as the weight will change
when moisture is released during the
cooking process
so we bake 425 degrees fahrenheit about
40 minutes
it's that easy now that your potatoes
are done just scoop those insides right
out
[Music]
you can process them with a potato
masher a strainer your fists
we wouldn't recommend that one actually
but what we do recommend is using a
potato ricer now we know not everyone
has one of these but it's the best way
to work with your potato pushing it
through a strainer or using the potato
masher will overwork your potatoes
giving your gnocchi a gummy texture and
we really don't want that
after you've riced them let the potatoes
cool releasing some of the steam will
get rid of excess moisture and the less
moisture you have the less flour you'll
need and the less flour you need the
lighter texture you'll get easy and
speaking of flour it's time to get to
our dough there's a big debate in the
gnocchi community yes that is a thing
about using eggs or not and we land on
the side of using them the eggs make the
dough easier to work with and your
gnocchi are more likely to hold their
shape when boiling if you're new to
making gnocchi it also gives you the
structure and stability you need when
first starting out think about the egg
as someone holding your hand whisk the
egg yolk and drizzle it evenly across
the potato mixture you want to do this
when the potato is cooled so that your
hot potatoes don't cook your eggs using
a bench scraper chop the mixture to
evenly distribute the egg yolk we found
a noticeable difference between
all-purpose flour and double o flour and
while ap can create a pretty tender
gnocchi double o flour is the clear
leader it's really finely ground and
gives her gnocchi a lighter texture than
the 8p that's a pretty good reason to
use it i'd say sift your flour over your
potato mixture sifting it helps with
distributing the flour evenly and it
helps you not overwork your dough then
sprinkle the salt across the top using
the bench scraper bring the mixture
together until a firm mass forms
gently fold the mixture over itself to
fully coat the potatoes in egg and flour
we can't stress enough the importance of
not overworking your dough don't do it
but if you don't bring your dough
together completely it will fall apart
when you go to boil your gnocchi so this
is really all about finding that sweet
spot between tough and tender once the
mixture forms a smooth ball roll the
dough into an eight inch log if your
dough is sticky add just enough flour to
make it workable but remember flour will
weigh down our gnocchi so be very
light-handed with this when you're
finished your dough should be soft
supple and a little bit sticky this is
the fun part cut a two inch piece from
the log and using the palm of your hands
roll the piece into an eight inch rope
with about a one inch diameter using
your bench scraper cut one inch pieces
rolling in the flour as needed so they
don't stick
repeat with the remaining dough
once your gnocchi is cut you can go
straight to boiling or you can take a
little extra time and give your gnocchi
these beautiful ridges we didn't find a
huge difference in how well a smooth or
texture gnocchi holds its sauce but it
looks damn good so we went for it we
used a pasta board for these you just
place your gnocchi on it press down
gentle now roll it and flick it's really
that easy and if you don't have a pasta
board you can just use a fork if you go
with this method just be careful about
how much pressure you use as pressing
down too hard can cause your gnocchi to
break this looks great and it's actually
kind of therapeutic too
finally it's time to get your gnocchi
cooking bring a large pot of salted
water to a boil place the gnocchi into
water and cook until they begin to float
that'll take about three minutes when
the gnocchi floats to the surface
they're done
stir them one so they don't stick but
don't get too crazy because they might
break
now the hard part is done so let's get
saucy
you can experiment and get really fancy
with your gnocchi sauces but we're going
to show you how to keep it simple and
make the two we think are the absolute
best first up is the pomodoro which is a
classic tomato base sauce it's velvety
it's creamy it's easy to make and it's
so delicious i just can't get enough of
this sauce heat your olive oil in a
large saucepan over medium heat add the
onions and cook until it begins to turn
golden brown and caramelized this should
take about 10 minutes add the garlic and
red chili flakes to the onions and
continue cooking until fragrant about 3
minutes toasting the red chili flakes
here instead of adding them in at the
end will allow the flavor to incorporate
better in the sauce you'll get a little
kick of spice in every bite this way
this process is called blooming add the
tomatoes oregano and salt and bring to a
boil this seriously looks so good i wish
you guys could smell this but you'll
understand when you make it yourselves
you've got to make it you have to
remove the sauce from the heat and add
the chopped basil
now use a hand blender to blend the
mixture until smooth return the sauce to
a medium low heat and stir in the heavy
cream make sure your heavy cream is room
temperature or else it'll curdle when
you add it and no one wants that
continue cooking until your sauce is
thickened slightly this should take
about three minutes now all that's left
to do is pour your sauce over the cook
gnocchi garnish with basil and you're
ready to eat this tastes so delicious i
mean seriously you have to try this the
only thing that might be better than the
pomodoro is this brown butter sage sauce
it's so rich and comes together in under
10 minutes this is all you need to make
a brown butter sage sauce you're going
to start by browning some butter place
the butter in a medium saucepan over
medium heat melt it until the butter
begins to turn golden brown and smells
nutty be sure to stir frequently then
you'll get you know blackened butter not
browned add the sage and red chili
flakes to the brown butter and remove
the pan from the heat keep stirring
until the sage and chili flakes are
lightly toasted stir in the lemon zest
in the salt this seriously smells so
good
[Music]
now just add your gnocchi to the sauce
and toss it until it's completely coated
that's it
the texture is so pillowy so light and
it absolutely just melts in your mouth
that might be one of the best sauces
you'll ever try it's absolutely heavenly
to finish it off just grate some
parmesan cheese on top and voila that's
how you make the best homemade gnocchi
that brown butter sage i mean forget it
it's the best when you try this recipe
for yourself you're gonna feel like a
total gnocchi pro guaranteed
oh yes
[Music]
you